this is the super bowl of the motion
picture business right here maybe the
pirate's life isn't for me the third
entry in the pirates of the caribbean
franchise upped the action and visuals
to deliver a thrilling experience let's
see what it was like making this
swashbuckling adventure
the gigantic ending battle between the
black pearl and dutchmen is one of the
biggest set pieces in movie history they
filmed the sequence in a military hangar
where they constructed a massive set it
required 920 feet of blue screen which
is one of the biggest in film history
electrical cables that stretched over
eight stories tall massive ships on
gimbal systems to rotate them and a
water system to simulate rain the pure
mass of this set is hard to comprehend
and all of this was designed and built
in just 3 months the visual effects side
of this battle was a massive undertaking
of its own as the sequence had over 320
vfx shots which made up one third of all
visual effect shots for the movie it
required a massive amount of computing
time i mean it was just mind-blowing the
entirety of the climactic fight between
the black pearl and dutchmen takes place
in the rain which meant the actors were
constantly getting soaked have you
noticed on top of everything it's
raining that's a bad sign the set had a
massive rain system that dumped water at
50 000 gallons a minute captain barbosa
actor jeffrey rush said when his costume
got wet he weighed 45 pounds more
the last 10 weeks shooting of the movie
they had nothing left to shoot that
wasn't in torrential rain
for 10 weeks orlando bloom stated that
there were some days of shooting where
they would be wet the entire day it
doesn't look too comfortable behind the
scenes but it looks fantastic on screen
how wet could a man be
speaking of being soaked apparently
that's just par for the course when you
work on a movie about sailing the high
seas for the sequence when the black
pearl is flipped over the actors
actually filmed that scene underwater
they would all synchronize a breath hold
and then go under and hold onto a rail
for as long as they could until they
needed air they even filmed righty and
pintel tied to the mast underwater which
was a little nerve-racking for the
actors not to worry though they had tons
of water safety experts on set just in
case of an emergency
it doesn't really feel like a good idea
to tie people up to a mast underwater
the dramatic and beautiful scene where
the endeavor ship gets torn to shreds
with beckett still on it is more
practical than you probably think all
the actors including beckett were filmed
separately from the exploding ship they
had a crew member counting on set so all
the actors could hit their marks at the
proper time
they then shot the same sequence but
this time with no actors they used
pyrotechnics and shot debris out of
cannons to simulate the ship blowing
apart motion controlled cameras were
used for both takes so the shots could
then be easily composited together for a
seamless sequence of beautiful
destruction
lucky here boys
a lost valve
if you thought davey jones sword
fighting with jack sparrow on a high
beam up in the air was fake you'd be
half right the fight was shot
practically with johnny depp and a davy
jones stunt double performing the fight
on a small piece of the set the long
swooping shot following this fight
starts off 100 cgi including johnny depp
then transitions into the real johnny
depp and stunt double performance it's a
perfect example of practical elements
and cg working together
step lively
how do you create a scene with multiple
jack sparrows you have johnny depp do
the same scene over and over and over as
different versions of himself depp had
to rehearse the scene character by
character applying small nuances to each
version it was great challenge you know
he and director gore verbinski came up
with the individual quirks of each jack
variation they used a motion controlled
camera for each take repeating the
sequence for as many jacks were in the
shot they then overlaid the takes in
camera to give depp and the crew an idea
of what it would look like
when you see it's working it juices you
up you know in another multi-jack
sequence we see mini jack sparrows on
johnny depp's shoulders interacting with
his hair for this they build giant
dreadlocks that johnny depp did the
scene with they had one dread that was
suspended in the air with depth hanging
onto it we love that they decided to do
this practically as the visual of johnny
depp standing in giant dreads is worth
it alone
i wash my hands of this weirdness how do
they make the ships in the movie look so
real simple they build them for real
well simpler said than done davey
jones's ship the dutchman was completely
built from scratch and was a real
sailboat with no motors it was inspired
by late 17th century design and
fittingly based on a dutch flute design
the design team used a urethane casting
a rubber-like substance to give the wood
an aged look on top of this all the
sculptures on the ship were created by
hand by their team of artists
there's so many man-hours involved in
this a combination of live-action ships
cgi and miniatures were used to bring
all the ships you see on screen to life
the scene where the black pearl and
dutchman surround the endeavor is a
perfect example of this technique the
black pearl was a real full-size ship
with some digital enhancements two
regular boats filled in for the other
ships and the wide shot of the endeavour
exploding was a miniature being blown up
ilm vfx supervisor john knoll stated the
importance of capturing a sequence in
camera first
my goal is to always start from some
live action so we've got some grounding
in reality that we can build from the
vast nothingness of davey jones's locker
is actually a real life location they
shot the scene at the bonneville salt
flats of utah the director loved the
look of it and the vastness of the
landscape it rained a couple days before
shooting which almost ruined everything
but luckily it dried up enough to film
the full-size black pearl wasn't there
and was instead johnny depp interacting
with small parts of the ship one scene
they shot here included a blooper of
johnny depp hitting the ground pretty
hard
our intentions are strictly honorable
the opening sequence of the film sees
captain barbosa and elizabeth swann
visiting captain fang's dwelling to ask
for assistance when things go south our
main characters have swords thrown to
them through the floorboards jeffrey
rush and keira knightley had
difficulties catching said swords the
actors throwing them had some troubles
as well after a handful of mistakes they
finally got a clean take
did you know that when this movie was
made in 2007 it was the most expensive
movie ever made costing 300 million
dollars even more shocking 14 years
later it is still one of the most
expensive films ever made only coming in
behind avengers infinity war end game
age of ultron and fittingly one of its
sequels on stranger tides after
everything we've learned though we
understand why it costs so much
so we just call it square then another
delightfully practical set piece came
when the crew rocks the black pearl to
capsize the ship the actors filmed the
scene on a rotating ship deck they
actually ran against the tipping of the
boat catching and holding onto the
railing for the wide shots of the boat
actually flipping over a 24 foot long
miniature was used
i caught on captain t
keeper of the code jack sparrow's
character and look was influenced by
rock legend keith richards who appears
in atworld's end as jack's father
costume designer penny rose wanted his
character's costume to be more elaborate
and aristocratic than jack sparrow's
more rough and weathered outfit they had
trouble getting enough materials to make
multiples of the costume but eventually
we're able to secure the necessary
supplies and give the character a unique
style
it's not just about living forever
jackie calypso turning into hundreds of
crabs is obviously a cgi effect but
would you have guessed that they
actually filmed practical elements of
this scene for the vfx team to work with
the crew used blue clay balls to fill in
for the crabs and dropped three large
nets filled with them onto the deck of
the black pearl it only took about five
seconds for all the balls to drop but
we're sure the cleanup took much longer
is that it
bringing pirates of the caribbean at
world's end to life was no easy task and
we have the utmost respect to everyone
that worked on the film it was truly an
amazing achievement in cinema which
behind the scenes facts surprised you
the most